you made me remember you dropped me to
that bad or chemicals that wasn't easy
to get over and don't think that I
didn't try classic scene come on
Superman Oh he'd be more of you Savannah
steel okay that's like the I'm sorry
iron man right close enough
those lives are that whole script isn't
bad in my brain I apologize okay but
this is you made me uh and this is the
return of Lemongrab unacceptable uh he's
back and he's I think he was looking for
people to rule over was that it I got a
little confused about that yeah that's
pretty much what it was is that he's all
alone in his is king he has no minion he
has no people or anything so he goes to
Bubblegum's Kingdom to it looks like
he's just watching him he doesn't wanna
take him to his kingdom so well he was
just watching him to see feel like yet
control yeah okay
that's at least always what I got from
it you know I'll give two minutes I'll
go through the rest of this it starts
off with this machine that they're using
that I just realized doesn't really come
back into anything and then Lemongrab
this I he wants people and it's Kingdom
or the or he just wants control like you
said so this was it the pumpking is that
was a see you know I can never fully
understand it and I never looked it up
or pop yeah are you sure I love those
kids I hope they come back they were
really funny what was again the big
money - money would ya love the big
cash-money wad was great for their
mothers you know just so they could get
their luck show their mom yeah linked
with mothers
sounds like much more development for a
bully than like any Stephen King story
I've read he's used him like a million
times Amy I'm like what twice in this
show or a couple times and it's like
they're all develop but they go and so
they go they tried to be just people for
the 411
grab and he puts him in a room that
again I'm not sure what it does does it
just take out the disloyalty you know it
is just them it is your shots them okay
it's a reconditioning see you bring up
Stephen King and it's really funny
because when I see that I think of the
short story quitters Inc okay or Jersey
cats I the guy was trying to quit
oh he's put in a room like that where
he's electrically shocked on the floor
oh yeah
so that's when I bring up Stephen King
what will sink there you go it all comes
full circle the circle of Steel's though
technically kingdoms do anything for
this but still but maybe he will maybe
Stephen King's adventure toy
everything's in Maine I can accept that
cuz weird does happening everyone's
either a religious nut and alcohol like
a writer or a bully and that's it yeah
sounds like my town okay my channel
awesome
I'm head hork so they go to so they got
E electric Jack's them so Finn Jake and
bubblegum they all go to try to save
them and talk some sense into them and
Finn and Jake it capture they're put in
the room and then bubblegum introduces
into a new Lemongrab because that's the
only person who would be satisfied to
rule over is himself Lemongrab oh and
and they're just both happy but okay so
it's cute it's fun and I like Lemongrab
surprisingly I'm always like am I get
again do I deal with him in this episode
something about the way this guy screams
they're all just distinct adjusts unnie
enough I know just the right note to hit
to not have it be annoying - shall we
get a giggle and for how long they
scream - son I'm surprised I actually
like those guys as much as I do but okay
yeah their machine in the opening that
goes nowhere you have a Finn jumping in
front of this sound sword that goes
nowhere
well I'm just realizing like unless this
stuff comes back which may be a will but
unless it comes back I'm like there
last stop I was introduced that just
sort of stops well fin jumping in front
of the sword I think kind of goes one of
two ways or both ways at the same time
he's heroic he's not gonna sit there and
let someone you know get hit by this
sword will do damn sword but they make
this like huge slo-mo thing and I
thought something's gonna happen to him
or he's gonna do Lynn would say is like
fight the dev off when it's also showing
that he still cares for peepee that was
the only other thing I could guess from
it which I'm sort of like I'll just let
that die Flame Princess come on it's
like I do someone said on extra credit
Evie will sit in the comment section and
I agree completely that it's not gonna
be that simple to just get over it there
will always be a special place for PB in
Finn's heart I think that's partially
what this was he's still willing to take
a bullet for her he's not romantically
into her and he realizes that she isn't
into him but he's still willing to go
that far for her I mean I guess it's one
of those things where it's like from one
standpoint true I mean once you're with
her you have at least a fascination for
someone that law gets aren't just uh up
and you know if you like but I guess
from a writing standpoint it's like I'm
just so done with it I'm like okay we're
done let's just go you know so rather
than focus on that focus more on like
him and maybe fire princess or something
like that or you know it's like I don't
know every time they bring that back
it's always like he could be another
episode focusing on their so focus I
wasn't focusing on it I know it's just
it's if I understood those strangest
thing no it usually means it's gonna
come back if it doesn't come back it's
like why I have it in there you know
like that there could have been other
ways to show like hey I'm still you know
Zoe's begat a bullet I thought we
already can do that and we didn't say
she shows it okay I mean it's I feel
like we could have seen that any other
but like with a knee or person but but
careful you may be called the c-word I
may be called candy
that's the c-word yes okay that's good
day
I'm benign um so and then I think the
other thing I forgot did people's
actually create Lemongrab
did I forgot the actual backstory she
you made me now I remember that but what
did she it's like if something happened
to her he was supposed to keep order was
that it yeah okay all right
why is he having some King to them okay
all right so something they've already
stated clearly that you know Lemongrab
just not get along with anyone
yeah he's a terrible that I shouldn't
say he's a terrible person and now I'm
not blaming PB don't yell at me but I
mean he was created imperfect if you
will so he has issue like one of my
favorite scenes is him with the baby
which doesn't sound like a baby
yeah McKee oh that's my fair isle of
what would people say she's going in
which I didn't think know if it was a
baby I thought it was just a guy and
this is just how you treat candy and he
does so much mercy they're very special
this is just because everybody in that
land is always happy and smiling and
dancing assistant it's like that could
just be an adult man and that's just how
they all act in that town I think would
be just funnier honestly it just looks
like that's how they would act in that I
loved lemongrabs response I mean the
reason why I think Lemongrab doesn't get
annoying like some other characters at
scream he's always saying something he's
not just going oh he's actually forming
sentences late I goes you know are your
are you crazy
yeah
like he's always saying something and
you're trying to at least me I'm trying
to follow what the hell he's saying it
does make the yeah I think that is part
of it is when you're saying something
and you you screaming you screaming such
a strange way the delivery you're used
to is altered and in what way is it
gonna be altered in it yeah what like if
you're say how are you but as they said
how are you it's like it's just strange
and it's weird and it might get a giggle
cuz you're so not used to it so yeah I
think if you do that it constantly and
how he talks yeah it's it's surprisingly
pretty funny plus he's a bizarre
character to begin with yeah I just um
remembering him at the window we sit
there any slowly sliding underneath and
he just stops doesn't dig his head out
when he's talking ladies like here
behind the window still talking this
falls out yeah it falls back why he
would go out the window that way like
backwards it just went yes oh boy yeah
yeah this one this episode had a lot of
funny little random things like then
just little like I love and they were
quick to which I like I like when finish
a you're gonna go and she just gets like
oh all these spikes and his tail isn't
okay let's go up and up a can and
everything and she's like no throw
peacefully make just kind of turns into
a flower okay and then she just jumps in
his mouth and then eat more sir out of
his back it's like weird little things
like that are really fun and I think
they make the episode stand out a little
bit more than just like I don't want to
say just a character developing at the
citizens are good episodes but it makes
it funnier it makes me want to go back
and watch again because I just like the
kinetic energy to it so uh yeah I like
to have a cheer of course it's Lemongrab
lemongrabs one of those characters that
yes I probably should hate considering
some of the characters I do dislike but
for some reason he's so bizarre and
alien and strength like he's the strange
one of all of the characters among all
of the characters in this show he's like
the most bizarre and strange and he just
does the oddest things I choose goose
was pretty always think weird sugars
characters I it was choose goose I
always choose goose or choose uterus
cuz he has a thing of juice
yes except this necklace I imagine he
was there instead the night from the
Last Crusade it was truth but choose
wisely make the movie least tolerable
wash your mouth you don't like Last
Crusade I need a mirror to watch my
mouth what you said watch my mouth wash
your mouth Oh wash them why would you
want to watch your mouth
are you set it yeah I said watch but
anything else to say about this um see
the O pb's hairstyle oh yes that's all I
forgot about that
that just cracked me up I remember
really early on I was sort of saying
like the first time I think they gave
her a different outfit I'm like so does
she only have two outfits and that's it
and it's almost like I think I'm saying
this stuff the same time that like when
the fan saw it they said the same thing
too because it's like something they're
giving her all these outfits and it's
like some are practical and some are
just strange and some are like what the
hell and I think that one just made me
laugh the heart it's just the weird I
don't know what's called but the braids
yes but like in the way around the brave
crowd crowd of braids you know it's
funny I liked it come on don't talk more
about Rosen right what's the word you
know the term the reamp
braids in the crown I speak for all
women when they say I don't know that's
right I forgot you always speak for all
what every single time we have you in
there it's like represents women always
so women you don't have a name for it
all women
yo Queen has spoken anyway